exciting times for you with the
announcement of the ipace you're joining
an increasingly crowded market for
electric cars aren't you first of all
good morning yes we are joining it but
we are doing in a typical checker alan
drove away we have developed and
designed an uncompromised 2 electric
reactor which gives us an opportunity to
have an optimized package a long range
and a totally new design language so we
are absolute uncompromised how many are
you intending to sell when when there
when it all gets into gear in 2018 I
mean you'd have to say that electric
cars aren't quite part of the sort of
mass conscious yet under a million sold
globally last year when are they gonna
really hit the road when are they gonna
really take off
Jaguar Land Rover at the moment I think
is in a poor position to really deliver
this very very purpose-built car I am
quite sure whenever we come in the
market in early 2018 that successors are
going to follow that competitors are
going to follow this kind of principle
and that we will see around about 20 20
40 50 percent of the overall product
portfolios being electrical offering
options in the direction of autonomous
connectivity and electrification but
routes how are you going to manage that
because regulations are getting more and
more difficult to meet by 2020 it could
be very difficult for your entire fleet
to meet the emissions regulations and
competitors like BMW say and and other
competitors have compact cars that help
them with the average emission
yeah at the end of the day it's quite
clear it's we will see more change in
the automotive industry in the next five
year than we have seen in the last 50
but that's a huge opportunity first of
all we have to redefine our core product
portfolio so other the internal
combustion engines and simultaneously we
are preparing for all these new features
more honest and a strong more connected
car safer cars and being doing it in
parallel so it's going to stretch the
team but the team is up for the
challenge and we will deliver very
interesting cars electric vehicles we
will comply okay well volkswagen has
pans for 30 so for example volkswagen
has plans for 30 electric vehicles and
coming years how many more do you have
in the pipeline
at the end of the day we are really
developing different kinds of
electrification and hybridization and
therefore we can comply with any legal
requirement mr. Speight there's all
sorts of pressures right now on
automakers worldwide to invest in
electric cars driverless cars mobility
solutions it's all happening what sort
of impact is that going to have on your
profit margin which reached a level of
ten point three percent in the last
quarter
yeah first of all our very special
prophet mastering for the last quarter
was influenced quite clear heavily by
the foreign exchange calculation as you
know with practice the pound has lowered
the value and therefore you must know
that we have to buy 50% of our bill of
materials in the European Union and in
addition we sell around about 100,000
cars to Europe with a heavy stock it's
quite clear that a wall foreign exchange
is a major driver of our profitability
overall I think that especially the
battery electric meters and also hyper
digitisation is going to help why
because seeing more of these kind of
products we are at a trigger point a
point where all of a sudden we not don't
deliver vehicles only to satisfy
regulatory schemes but work with the
customer to really have in the eyepiece
for instance a sports car performance
with elegance with personality and with
the practicality of an SUV so it's a
very highly attractive product